OK, let's go next to. Oh, this
is interesting. I don't think
we've ever had a call from Uruguay.
Let's go to Grecia from Uruguay,
which of course means grasshopper.
A yes, grasshopper, I'm calling again, Mr. Padman,
I had a call with you a few months ago.
Oh, you did? I apologize. I forgot
about it.
No, there's no need to apologize.
And remind me, are you are you and you're in
Montevideo or are you in Colonia? Where are you?
No, I am in Montevideo. You are
like five or six years. Got it. OK,
I am originally from Argentina. I am from
the. But I want to ask dinner. Oh, all
right. Beautiful.
So. Well, first I wanted to ask you if you are
doing well and I really hope you do.
I'm doing well. Yes. Thank you.
And then I have two really different
topics. Yeah. OK, one, if it's possible,
I wanted to ask you in Spanish. Sure. Yet when
they go through NASA alone. So when you see,
OK, so I recently posted to my
Instagram, I was able to obtain a dozen
essentially Argentinean chrysanths, which
we call in Argentina Medy aloofness,
which means like Half Moon. And I think you can
imagine it sort of looks like a crescent moon.
They were they were very good, but it was not
exactly what we would call an Argentinean,
Maria Luna, but it was pretty good.
OK, yeah, I'll get you for that. OK,
good. And and then the second part for sure is in
English. I wanted to ask about if you have heard
this, I think it's kind of like a leak
or a declaration about the but basically
the US influence Brazil. So not to take this
Sputnik vaccine. What have you heard about that?
I did hear about it. I don't know.
I mean, has it been confirmed?
And I have seen it in different news sources.
Yeah, I'm from Argentina, one that is literally
like Sputnik News. So it's kind of
know maybe you go for a different
source than Sputnik News. But, yes, I.
I know the allegation has been made.
Yeah, it has to be, because here, in a way,
I do think that basically the same happened
because the Argentinian government offered
the tourism government the vaccine and it
will do. I am going to basically like look to the
other side and literally wait three more months
to get any vaccine. We recently like, I think the
first week of March, we had the first scene of
vaccines. Right. So just a question
is like, do you think this is kind of
what is left of the policy of Trump
trying to influence all these,
like Latin America in general?
Yeah, I mean, listen, that goes back well
beyond Donald Trump. And because I just I don't
know the truth of that story. It's hard for me to
comment on it. What I do know is that the we have
this phrase here. The proof is in the pudding.
Other than Chile, vaccination in South America
has been a disaster. And I'm sure there are many
reasons for it. You know, in Argentina, you might
have seen they make this big show of an erroneous
Hurricane Dean playing plane, flying to Moscow
and then back. And they welcome it at the airport
heroically and like nobody's getting vaccinated.
And meanwhile, Chile, with very little show,
has one of the highest vaccination rates in
the world and the highest in South America.
It's like emblematic of the ongoing
problems with a lot of these governments.
Yeah, for sure. And then I want to just at
one little more, because I thought that I had.
Yeah. And Trump talking about show. He made a
big show about that. I think it's two billion
dollars for the for the operation. Warp
speed. Yeah. I think I'd add about that.
And you have said that operation was worth it.
It was almost like if he didn't do something
to to to put vaccine to work and that day that
it would be like negligent basically. Yes. So
I thought about like maybe he did such a big
movement and he, like, moved a lot of money and he
didn't get any results. And that's why he might be
of there might be some of these influence to like,
hey, don't get any other vaccine, because I have
seen the tweets and things like that about not
even getting the AstraZeneca vaccine or the see
what it's like anywhere else. Get like don't get
any other vaccine that is not there that the
US wants. I mean, listen, I thought I had it.
It's it's it's totally speculative, but it would
be very consistent with the way Donald Trump sees
the world. I think we
can say that,
yeah, it's full of speculation at one
hundred percent. I don't have any source,
but. Yeah, well, nothing else. David,
big, big hug. Right. Wrestle with America
and have a beautiful day at Grecia.
Before you go, one question. When
I was in Montevideo a few years ago, I
went to correct me if I'm wrong. The the
market downtown. Is it a miracle?
Puerto Rico in politics?
It was amazing. And it's like this indoor
market with all these different, you know,
food stands. There were so many Americans
there humiliating themselves and attracting a
lot of attention. Is that common that American
tourists at the Puerto embarrass themselves?
And they kind of and not only there, I work in
a hotel that is basically on the opposite side
of Montevideo. Yeah, I'm right behind that. There
is a really good grill, you know, like I really
like that rail that is there since the
60s. So you do know what they are doing
that is really, really useful to City to see the
faces of the of the people serving there. Like I
cannot believe. Oh, no, that's horror.
That's humiliating
everywhere. There are plenty of people
from anywhere in the world, I guess,
getting humiliated, humiliated. Sorry.
That's true. Markets everywhere, all
over the world. Yes. It's not unique
to Hawaii or America. All right,
Grecia, appreciate the call. Thank you
for sure. They have a beautiful day.
All right. You, too. All right, guys, let's end on
a perfect phone call. I don't know that we could
have had a more perfect phone call than that.
I apologize, as always, that I'm not able to
get to everyone. But we'll keep taking calls
and I'll keep hearing from many more of you